[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les matins du
sénat depuis le 1er février le royaume
uni ne fait plus partie de l'union
européenne
l'heure est désormais aux négociations
autour d'un accord sur les futures
relations entre londres et bruxelles
ces négociations doivent durer jusqu'au
31 décembre elles seront entre autres
conduites pas amélie de montchalin la
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes et est auditionné par le
sénat à ce sujet on regarde l'audition
on en parle juste après merci madame le
ministre d'avoir accepté de venir à une
heure qui dès pas très facile pour les
uns et les autres mais vous voyez par là
la qualité et la quantité de sénatrices
et sénateurs qui ont souhaité venir vous
entendre le sujet de nous allons
débattre nous intéresse évidemment
alors madame la ministre le compte à
rebours a commencé et nous avons compris
y compris à la faveur de déclarations
récentes de la partie britannique
les choses vont être compliqués et
difficiles la négociation avec les
britanniques va être ardue parce que en
quelques semaines les choses ont malgré
tout légèrement changé les britanniques
sont désormais unis les britanniques
sont unis même si les divisions en
irlande et en écosse
reste évidemment préoccupante mais la
détermination du premier ministre
johnson est maintenant clair ils
refusent tout alignement avec l'union
européenne
alors on peut imaginer bien sûr que
c'est une position de départ une
position offensive alors que débute la
négociation c'est sans doute le cas
mais ne nous y trompons pas le peuple
britannique a voulu le break cité le
premier ministre johnson va le mettre en
place notamment pour mettre fin à la
libre circulation telle qu'on la
connaissait avec la grande bretagne
telle qu'on la connaît encore mais tel
qu'on l'a vécu dans le cadre européen et
donc les présidents de vos deux
commissions mon collègue excellente ami
jean bizet et moi même
on souhaitait déposer lundi dernier une
proposition de résolution européenne en
application de notre règlement afin que
notre assemblée dans cette affaire
compliquée difficile puissent faire
entendre sa voix et je voudrais jean le
complétera à souligner quelques points
en particulier qui sous l'angle de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
singulièrement de la défense nous nous
soucie tout d'abord le 1er mai premier
ministre britannique a indiqué vouloir
une série limitée
d'accord on se souvient au départ on
partait sur 120 d'accord maintenant il
semble que il n'y en aura - boris
johnson estime en particulier que la
coopération en matière de politique
étrangère et de défense ne nécessite ni
nouveau traité ni nouvelle institution
ce n'était du reste pas la position de
theresa may et donc vous nous direz
madame la ministre qu'elle est la
position du gouvernement sur ce point
pour faire en sorte que nous ayons le
meilleur cadre pour continuer une
coopération dans le domaine de la
sécurité de la défense qui nous paraît
essentiel et incontournable de la même
manière la france avait proposé un
conseil de sécurité européen qui pouvait
bien sûr associé le royaume uni sans
porter atteinte à l'autonomie de
décision de l'union européenne
cette proposition risque d'avoir
quelques difficultés et est ce que là on
véritablement un avenir
or la question ne se pose comment
envisager une future coopération entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
dans des domaines politique étrangère et
de défense sans la mise en place d'un
cadre commun permanent d'information de
dialogue de coopération
et est ce que ce point risque de sortir
de la négociation globale en laissant la
coopération qui est vraiment de qualité
nous connaissons la qualité de nos deux
armées britannique et française mais ils
n'ont pas il nous apparaît qu'un cadre
serait nécessaire de la même manière
nous n'avons eu de cesse de dire que
nous souhaitions que le royaume uni
puisse participer à l'effort capacitaire
de défense commune notamment au travers
la coopération structurée permanente et
le fonds européen de la défense mais là
encore peut-être avez-vous quelques
précisions le royaume uni souhaitent ils
lui même entré dans ces deux dispositifs
pour l'instant il ne participe toujours
pas la coopération structurée permanente
et donc dès lors chers collègues au
moment même où les choses s'éclairent
dans le cadre de la coopération avec
l'allemagne puisque je serai demain avec
un certain d'entre vous me sers de la
défense pour signer la la préfiguration
du scaf avec la ministre allemande de la
défense et le ministre espagnol
mais nous sommes toujours sur ces
grandes questions de l'avenir de la
défense européenne
nous savons que le royaume uni joue un
rôle essentiel dans l'architecturé de
sécurité de l'europe et notamment dans
sa base industrielle et technologique de
défense est fameuse baie itd est donc là
aussi comment va-t-on pouvoir inclure
nos amis britanniques dans cette
construction difficile lente mais
absolument nécessaire d'une défense
européenne tel que le souhaite le
président de la république mais je pense
que tel que le souhaite aussi nombre
d'entre nous au delà de nos sensibilités
respectives
le conseil européen doit examiner demain
le futur cadre financier pluriannuel
or là nous de vous le savez où nous en
avons fait pas mal à ma miss nous sommes
très inquiets de la réduction de moitié
envisagée par nos très bons amis
finlandais pour le budget du fonds
européen de défense
alors c'est peut-être une position de
principe et ce n'est que le début de la
négociation
enfin cet effort de 13 milliards était
tout à fait substantiel est vraiment
montré le sens dans lequel comme l aller
et revenir à 6 milliards ce serait
évidemment une marche arrière qui serait
très mal comprise et bien évidemment est
ce que là aussi l'ambition d'une
autonomie stratégique risque évidemment
d'être remise en cause
au titre de notre commission nous
appelons bien évidemment le gouvernement
à veiller à la bonne application de
l'accord de retrait cette bonne
application sous des sous des points
aussi importants que par exemple le
droit des citoyens
quatre millions et demi de personnes
sont concernées je le rappelle l'accord
de retrait leur fournit certes un
certain nombre de garanties mais il ya
encore beaucoup d'incertitudes pour les
citoyens qui sont actuellement établie
et plus encore pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient s'y établirent s'établir
de chaque côté de la frontière puisque
c'est ça dont il faut parler après le
1er janvier 2021
or cette question des citoyens est
supposé régler ne fait pas partie de la
négociation future
quelles seront donc les pouvoirs de la
commission pour faire respecter l'accord
de retrait sur ce point et maintenir la
vigilance nécessaire concernant le
fameux protocole sur l'irlande du nord
qui nous a tous les uns et les autres
occupé beaucoup l'an dernier et qui doit
préserver la paix et la stabilité en
irlande
ce point est également supposé réglée
par l'accord de regrets de retrait de
regrets aussi du reste mais celui ci
implique la mise en place effective d'un
dispositif frontalier en mer d'irlande
là encore il va falloir rester très
vigilant et vous nous direz madame la
mini psy le royaume uni et l'union
européenne ont commencé à préparer la
mise en oeuvre de dispositions de
l'accord de retrait sur ce point enfin
et j'en terminerai par là en cadets en
haven dans le cas de dans l'éventualité
d'un accord qui malgré tout reste aussi
toujours possible au 31 décembre de
cette année ou d'un accord a minima
quelles sont les mesures que le
gouvernement français est que l'union
européenne envisage car bien sûr l'an
dernier dans l'urgence un certain nombre
de mesures ont été prises dans
l'éventualité d'un arbre excitant
est ce qu'elles sont suffisantes et est
ce que nos entreprises sont aidées pour
se préparer suffisamment tôt et
efficacement à une telle éventualité
voilà quelques soucis qui ont retenu et
qui retiennent à la fois l'attention de
la la commission mixe que j'ai l'honneur
de coprésider avec jean est aussi aux
titres de la commission à vincent géré
la défense des questions qui nous
interpelle et pour lesquels vos réponses
seront les bienvenues madame la ministre
merci ce président merci cher christian
madame la mise permettez moi avant de
m'adresser directement à vous de
remercier le présent marché compte tenu
du fait que maintenant nous rentrons
dans une nouvelle phase l'accord de
relations futures et christian cambon et
moi même avons pris l'initiative de lui
demander que n'ayant pas pu signaler
votre présence parce qu on était un
petit peu dans des jets dirait père et
de contraintes
on a fait abstraction de la décision de
la conférence des présidents des
présidents pardon et en application de
l'article 6 de l'article 23 bis à cette
réunion étaient ouvertes à tous les
sénateurs
je pense qu on renouvellera l'exercice
sur cette partie quand tu auras des
points clés parce que c'est un sujet
plus particulier nous sommes heureux
madame les minutes de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui pour évoquer la nouvelle
page qui s'ouvre effectivement dans
l'histoire de l'union européenne en
raison d'un retrait d' dans ses membres
pas n'importe lequel la troisième
économie de la zone euro
et ceci est effective depuis deux
semaines l'union européenne a été
éprouvée par les trois années et demi
qui viennent de s'écouler passé à
concrétiser la volonté du peuple
britannique exprimée dans les urnes juin
l'accord de retrait finalement conclu en
octobre dernier a été le fruit de
négociations ardues entre l'union et le
royaume uni quand ça même du royaume uni
une nouvelle négociation tout aussi ardu
je pense peut-être plus encore s'engage
à présent dans des délais encore plus
contraints puisqu'elle doit se conclure
d'ici la fin de l'année sauf
prolongation a demandé avant la fin juin
mais le premier ministre britannique
monsieur johnson s'ils refusent déjà sur
ce point là même s'ils changent de temps
en temps des vies je ne pense qu'il n'en
changera pas il s'agit de rebâtir une
nouvelle relation euro britannique dans
toutes ses dimensions
nos économies sont étroitement imbriqués
l'union étant le premier fournisseur et
client
du royaume uni et la géographie nous
gardera très proches et nos liens
historiques sont profonds deux chiffres
vue si je puis dire des 27 capitales de
l'union européenne les flux en direction
de londres sans hauteur de 47% et vue je
dirais non
9 % par 9% et dans l'autre sens ils sont
de 47 pour ça donc si vous voulez c'est
quand même extrêmement claire souvenez
vous de ces deux chiffres
47% dans un sens neuf bourses dans
l'autre en matière de flux économiques
établir un nouveau partenariat entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni est
donc impératif mais aussi compliqué de
nombreux sujets sont sur la table ou
plutôt les tables de négociations nous
nous félicitons que la promotion mandat
de négociation soit global et couvre
l'ensemble de ces sujets car nous avons
sur les uns des intérêts offensifs et
sur les autres des intérêts défensif et
seul un accord couvrant le tout pour ra
être équilibré j'avoue que on est dans
l'architecturé de ce qui se passe niveau
de l'organisation
comment dirais-je de l'organe de l'om
sait rien et négocier tout pendant que
tout n'est pas négocier et il apparaît
qu'il ya deux sujets si vous voulez
qu'ils vont nous occupe essentiellement
la pêche et les services financiers
ce point de vue nous nous interrogions
sur un élément de calendrier dans sa
proposition de mandat de négociation la
commission propose que les dispositions
en matière de pêche soit établie d'ici
le 1er janvier 2020 afin de pouvoir
juillet juillet 2020 afin de pouvoir
déterminer attend les possibilités de
pêche en 2021
or justement matière de pêche nous
sommes particulièrement inquiet car nous
avons absolument besoin de conserver un
accès aux eaux britanniques pour nos
pêcheurs qui font la moitié de leurs
reese ça varie en fonction des régions
ça va de 30 à 45%
mais d'un autre côté les prises de
poissons britanniques ont besoin de
l'union à hauteur de 75% pour pouvoir
s'écouler cette dispute cette
disjonction de calendrier entre la pêche
et le reste de la négociation me semble
dangereuse
n'avons nous pas intérêt à garder dans
la même corbeille de négociations la
pêche sujet nous avons surtout des
intérêts défensif
elles restent des sujets où nous avons
des intérêts offensifs susceptibles de
venir en compensation je pense au ciel
européen en l'occurrence bref ne
risque-t-on pas un mauvais accord sur la
pêche
s'il est conclu isolement du reste
deuxième sujet de préoccupation quelle
forme juridique prendre à la corde
commercial qui sera conclu entre l'union
européenne mais le moins et le royaume
uni s'agira-t-il d'un accord mixte cela
impliquerait une ratification par chaque
état membre
si l'on tient compte du temps que
requiert la ratification de l'accord non
seulement par le royaume uni l'union
européenne mais aussi par les états
membres cela impliquerait de conclure la
négociation
plusieurs semaines ou mois avant le 31
décembre 2020
donc cela est courte encore la phase
utile de négociations et si c'est un
accord mixte est ce que la jurisprudence
singapour s'appliquera si je peux dire
la partie de la mixité sera extrêmement
ténu en france au niveau des parlements
nationaux il nous resterait pas grand
chose je dirais à débattre
troisième motif d'inquiétude nous
entrons dans une phase plus délicate où
chaque état membre n'a pas les mêmes
intérêts à défend dans cette négociation
avec le royaume uni
l'unité qui a prévalu entre les états
membres durant la négociation de
l'accord de retrait risque d'être
fragilisée
quel est votre pronostic à cet égard
reconnaître que ça a été
une petite surprise mais une grande
satisfaction de voir que pendant les
trois années de négociations sous
l'autorité de michel barnier
l'unité de 27 n'a fait défaut à aucun
moment et je le dis souvent nous avons
pris collectivement conscience que nous
étions copropriétaire du premier marché
économique mondiale ce qui n'était pas
apparu aussi je dirais nettement depuis
depuis plus de 50 ans donc
souhaitons que cette unité à 27 perdure
enfin puisque nous sommes à la veille du
conseil européen extraordinaire sur le
cadre financier pluriannuel je ne peux
manquer de vous interroger sur la place
la nature du compromis que charles
michel entrevoit ce sujet sur ce qu'il
adviendra des priorités du scénar la
matière qu'il a signé au gouvernement
dans une récente résolution européenne
n'a pas été la seule nous devrons
plusieurs résolutions sur ce point et
qui sur la partie entre guillemets
agricole est restée lettre morte nous
avons fait trois et nous avons jamais eu
de réponse sur ce sujet on voit se
dessiner se cristalliser je dire l
architecture financière du cadre
financier pluriannuel et il ya plutôt
des motifs d'inquiétude
merci madame la ministre pour vos
réponses voilà madame la ministre voit
là un certain nombre de questions
notamment ici goût theater et sénateurs
des français de l'étranger qui sont
directement interpellé seul arrêt des
régions hôtes france normandie puis bien
sûr d'autres régions nous écoutons vos
réponses selon le cadre habituel un
exposé d'une quinzaine vingtaine de
minutes et puis après il y aura un
échange avec la salle
merci madame hamm unis merci messieurs
les présidents mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices effectivement
leur est un peu inhabituel inhabituel
mais nous sommes au coeur d'une semaine
européenne très intense puisque
s'ouvrira demain un conseil européen
extraordinaire sur le budget je vous le
dis en manière préliminaire puisque vous
m'avez interrogé sur le sujet nous
portons quatre grands types de priorité
la première c'est l'agriculture
il nous faut absolument sécuriser les
moyens de la pac
nous ne pouvons pas demander aux
agriculteurs de faire plus avec moins
d'argent et donc nous cherchons toujours
à maintenir non seulement au niveau
français mais également au niveau
européen
l' enveloppe dédiée à pâques en euros
courants pour que entre 2014
il vint à 27 et 2021 et 2027 à 27 nous
ayons à minima les mêmes moyens
ça c'est la première de nos priorités la
deuxième sur la cohésion nous cherchons
à préserver les régions en transition
qui sont toutes les régions de métropole
sauf ile-de-france et auvergne
rhône-alpes
comme vous le savez pour leur donner des
moyens d'investissement notamment aux
services locaux que vous connaissez tous
très bien et ce qu'on appelle en jargon
bruxellois les régions ultra
périphériques qui sont de l'outre-mer
une partie des outre mers parce que vous
savez qu'il ya deux catégories mais en
tout cas pour les régions
ultrapériphériques et pour les p t om
comme on dit à ce stade nous avons
encore beaucoup d'efforts à faire
c'est pour tous les français que
l'europe travaille c'est aussi pour tous
les français quelle que soit leur
localisation géographique troisième type
de priorité c'est ce qu'on appelle les
priorités thématiques que ce soit les
priorités pour la défense de l'espace
également d'erasmus à ce nombre de
programmes qui sont extrêmement
important à notre crédibilité à notre
souveraineté à l'avancement de projets
que nous portons vous savez grâce à vous
d'ailleurs souvent avec beaucoup
d'ambition et quatrième bloc c'est ce
qu'on appelle les ressources propres
c'est que nous pensons qu'il n'y a pas
d'accord possible entre ceux qui
s'appellent eux-mêmes les frigos et ceux
qui de leur côté attendent beaucoup plus
de l'europe
si nous n'avons pas des ressources
propres parce que nous voulons pas
augmenter les impôts qui pèsent sur les
français sur les contribuables qui
paient déjà des impôts
maintenant nous voyons qu'il ya
énormément d'acteurs qui bénéficient du
marché intérieur qui n'y contribue pas
je pense au garage pour son acteur
financier des grans des importateurs de
plastique par exemple qui ne leur cycle
pas ou encore des entreprises qui
contribuent fortement à la pollution ça
qu'on et cherche à voir si avec le
marché ets qui ce marché des permis co2
en europe on a possibilité d'autres les
ressources donc je crois que c'est assez
convergent avec les priorités d'ailleurs
du sénat et des résolutions vous avez pu
faire nous allons avec le président dans
ce débat de manière assez offensive et
je vous lis devant vous nous
n'accepterons pas
un accord qui mettrait l'europe au
rabais parce qu'il ya le sujet des
rabais nous sommes pas prêts nous
contributeurs nets à mettre de l'argent
sur la table pour indéfiniment et bien
donner de l'argent à nos voisins
ça nous semble être extrêmement
politiquement désormais on peut paraître
juste dans un système on fait des
chèques les uns les autres comme disait
madame thatcher et nous devons pas non
plus d'une europe au rabais qui sous
prétexte que nous avons effectivement un
membre de moins nous serions moins
ambitieux - - - capable en fait de
répondre aux demandes des citoyens
voilà l'esprit qui est nôtre cette
semaine est également bien sûr chargé
par le break dit michel barnier était à
matignon lundi matin pour un rayon de
ministres autour du premier ministre ou
grande majorité du gouvernement était de
fait présent et je crois que votre
présence ici nombreuses montrent bien
que d'un sujet transverse qui a eu un
peu plus de poids géographique dans
certaines régions que d'autres mais qui
est aussi un sujet qui concerne presque
l'intégralité de nos politiques puisque
c'est l'intégralité au fond de lui aussi
du mécanisme européen qui est impactée
alors pour détailler les choses plus
précisément wilbur exit est une réalité
puisque le royaume uni a quitté l'union
européenne au 31 janvier de manière
politique il ya plus de commissaires de
tanis qui peut député européen
britannique il ya plus ministre
britannique dans les réunions à
bruxelles
c'est un choix souverain choix
démocratique nous l'avons souvent dit
respectons ce choix et l'important était
pour nous les conditions de retrait
puisque après plus de trois ans
négociation vous savez que notre
objectif était que nous ayons un bon
accord pour des choses se passent de
manière ordonnée
c'est le cas cela a notamment permis et
c'était une priorité du gouvernement
largement d'ailleurs discuter avec vous
depuis maintenant quelques mois de
protéger en particulier droits des
citoyens préserver les conditions de
séjour et de travail à la fois des
citoyens français résidant au royaume
uni pour qu'ils puissent continuer à
vivre à travailler à étudier dans les
mêmes conditions de celle que celles qui
existent aujourd'hui et réciproquement
permettre aux citoyens britanniques sur
les territoires français de garder les
mêmes droits et quelles conséquences que
vous connaissez notamment sur les
élections les citoyens britanniques ne
peuvent plus se présenter aux élections
municipales
il n'est pas fou non plus voter puisque
c'est un droit qui était réservé aux
citoyens de l'union européenne
nous serons et vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président est
vraiment vigilants sur la mise en oeuvre
en particulier des dispositions prévues
dans l'accord de retrait sur les droits
des citoyens et notamment la mise en
oeuvre de l'autorité de surveillance
indépendante pour les droits des
citoyens que lors que le royaume uni
doit mettre en place au titre de
l'accord de retrait
c'est un de nos points de vigilance pour
le dire clairement nous entrons dans une
nouvelle négociation mais si les
engagements pris dans la négociation qui
vient de se terminer ne sont pas tenues
eh bien vous imaginez bien que le cadre
de confiance général va être impactée et
donc les engagements pris doivent être
tenues et strictement tenu outre ce
volet l'accord de retrait est garantie
par le règlement financier que le
royaume uni honore ses engagements
contractés pour le dire simplement tout
ce qui a été décidé à 28 sera bien payés
à 28
et donc il ya un nombre de versements
qui continueront d'avoir lieu dans les
années qui viennent
le coût de la sortie d'une certaine
manière est donc bien à charge du
royaume uni c'est d'accord protège aussi
nos entreprises puisque nous sommes
entrés dans cette fameuse transition où
le droit européen continue de
s'appliquer pleinement au royaume uni au
moins jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020 et ça
assure une forme de prévisibilité je
crois que c'était extrêmement important
d'avoir bataillé pour que les choses se
fassent ainsi maintenant nous devons
négocier les termes de la relation
future
pendant cette période transition nous
voyons les choses ne changent pas nous
avons donc un petit sas j'allais dire
moment tampon qui nous permettent de
négocier dans un cadre si je peux dire
ainsi apaisé mais nous voyons que la
période délais de négociation a été fixé
par bordeaux lui même à onze mois et j'y
reviendrai ce calendrier ne doit pas
nous détourner de l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est d'avoir un accord qui
soit un accord équilibré ambitieux
conforme aux intérêts de l'union
parce que je vais y revenir nous ne
pouvons pas demander aux acteurs
économiques aux entreprises aux pêcheurs
aux agriculteurs de l'union européenne
et en particulier la france de se
retrouver face à une concurrence
déloyale ou nouvelles sous prétexte que
nous sommes pas capables de les protéger
par un accord qui serait celui qui est
nécessaire pour garder l'équilibré et la
loyauté que nous avons vue pendant 47
ans ceux déployés de part et d'autre de
la manche attendra-t-elle accord n'est
pas chose aisée les sujets sont
complexes
ils sont nombreux nous sommes également
nombreux autour la table et donc nous
devons éviter un stand d'écueils que
j'aimerais vous présenter le premier
écueil à nos yeux serait de revenir sur
nos principes et nos ambitions
parce que nous y serions ainsi tu es tu
peux dire ainsi par des déclarations les
positions de boris johnson qui déclarent
depuis maintenant quelques semaines
qu'il ne voit aucune raison de se
contraindre par un accord avec l'union
européenne et qui refusent en
particulier le concept même de
conditions de concurrence équitables ou
en belle l'anglais de level playing
field
je tiens à le dire ici très
solennellement ses mots cette attention
cette ambition ne sont pas une invention
des européens qui se serait produite au
début de l'année 2020 ces mots cette
intention sont au coeur de la
déclaration politique qui a accompagné
l'accord de retrait laquelle déclaration
politique a été approuvée par le conseil
européen par le parlement européen par
le gouvernement britannique et par le
parlement britannique
donc ce qui vous explique aujourd'hui
que tout cela serait voyez le diktat
européen qui se poursuivrait oublie que
nous travaillons en ce sens parce que
c'est ce sur quoi nous nous étions mis
d'accord dans l'accord de retrait cette
déclaration politique qui l'accompagné
je crois que l'union ne doit pas
craindre d'affirmer ses ambitions et ses
principes ni de rappeler que les droits
qu'ils pourront être accordées n'iront
pas sans obligation le degré d'ouverture
commerciale dépend de la capacité à
faire converger nos règles et principes
assez simple plus on s'ouvre est bien
plus on se met en capacité d'être dans
une relation équilibrée et loyal c'est
aussi la protection du projet européen
qui est en jeu il sera extrêmement
difficile de prendre des accords entre
nous à 27
si nous savons d'ores et déjà que nous
avons un concurrent comme le lierre
angela merkel à nos pas
qui ne s'appliquera pas ces mêmes règles
je peux penser à des exemples domaine
environnemental
le green deal européen est un mécanisme
qui va nous obliger à faire des choses
différemment qui coûtera parce qu'il
devra d investissement et nous ne
pouvons pas tolérer que nous soyons sur
les mêmes marchés sur les mêmes biens et
bien récepteur de produits qui ne
respectera pas ses nouvelles règles que
nous nous imposons nous mêmes pour de
bonnes raisons bien l'axé l'autonomie
décision de l'union européenne qui est
potentiellement en jeu le deuxième
écueil cesserai de céder à la pression
du temps en intériorisant les
contraintes de calendrier politique qui
est qui sont celles du gouvernement
britannique pour des raisons intérieures
et c'est pour ça que nous devons veiller
et je pense que nous y travaillons
ensemble à ce qu'à chaque étape le fond
prime sur le calendrier
comme je dis souvent nous ne signerons
pas le vin le 31 décembre 2020 à 23h un
mauvais accord sous prétexte de signer
et un tel accord nous emmène pour 20 ou
30 ans pour plusieurs décennies
si nous signons à contrecoeur et nous le
regrettons pendant vingt ou trente ans
il verra un sujet je pense de cohérence
politique à éviter troisième écueil
cette pensée que la situation après le
retrait peut être comme avant
le stade sud états tiers a des
conséquences en port des conséquences et
c'est un fait il ne peut pas être aussi
avantageux que l'appartenance à l'union
et nous devons donc continuer à
sensibiliser les entreprises aux
citoyens tous nos partenaires à cette
nouvelle réalité il n'y aura pas de
statu quo je tiens aussi à dire il ya
plus de poésie de cohésion au royaume
uni il ya plus de politique agricole
commune au royaume uni il ya plus à sam
de cadres des changes
je pense à europol eurojust les
mécanismes en tant que telle ne
fonctionne plus pareil et le royaume uni
est devenu soit un pays qui est sorti
des mécanismes soient qui peut les
rejoindre à nouveau en tant que pays
tiers est à thiers je vais revenir mais
qui ne donne pas les mêmes droits qui
n'ont pas les mêmes facilités et puis
pour finir pour s'assurer de cette
cohérence et la préservation des
intérêts effectivement l'écueil qu'il
faut éviter c'est que nous divisions
entre nous 27 dans les priorités dans
notre message
la plus grand de nos forces au cours des
quasi mans 3 2 3 ans et demi passés a
été notre capacité derrière michel
barnier
à tenir un front commun alors pour
clarifier les choses et avant d'entendre
vos questions comment les choses se
passent elles de manière continue
calendrier et d'état le 3 février
dernier michel barnier a présenté un
projet de directives de négociation un
projet de mandat qui fait l'objet de
discussions depuis pour s'assurer que
les principes et les objectifs posés
reflète bien l'intérêt l'union ce mandat
doit être approuvé mardi prochain lors
du conseil des ministres des affaires
générales où je siège pour que nous
puissions effectivement lancer des
négociations avec les britanniques la
première semaine de mars
oui les choses sont vont s'accélérer
dans la préparation du mandat de l'union
et pour la conduite des négociations
nous avons et vous les avez rappelé des
points de vigilance absolue pour
préserver nos citoyens nos agriculteurs
nos pêcheurs nos entreprises et nous
sommes avec notre ambassadeur qui
prépare bien sûr ce texte demande à
amender nous sommes en train de préciser
de renforcer aussi la main du
négociateur pour les mois qui viennent
le partenariat que nous avons à bâtir
est effectivement inédit par son attend
son étendue sa configuration sa
profondeur et il faut bien comprendre
que au delà des sujets thématiques sur
lequel nous devons nous mettre d'accord
et bien suite gouvernance il ya un sujet
de règlement des différends des
potentiels sanctions rétorsion clause de
sauvegarde puisque le royaume uni ne
souhaite pas que cela soit fait par la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
si le règlement des différends n'est
plus fait par la cour de justice l'union
peine il faut bien que ça fait par
quelqu'un est donc ce cadre de
gouvernance transversale est un socle
institutionnel majeur pour que nous
ayons non seulement des engagements mais
la capacité de contrôler la bonne mise
en oeuvre des engagements pris et que
nous puissions également et bien avoir
des mécanismes de sanction de rétorsion
si les engagements pris ne sont pas
tenus il ya un cadre à éviter c'est
celui de la suisse pour ceux d'entre
vous qui le connaîtrai parce que les
accords avec la suisse ont été fait de
manière progressive
certains d'entre vous les connaissent
régionalement en particulier les choses
se sont accumulées dans le temps mais le
il n'y a jamais eu de cas de gouvernance
à ce stade commun et donc les sanctions
les rétorsions se font sujet par sujet
mais le cadre de gouvernance que nous
voulons créer c'est que nous puissions
je prends des exemples à titre
illustratif
sinon des difficultés sur un type de
bien que nous puissions avoir une
attention sur un autre volet de la
politique bien ancrée de la
transversalité et donc de la capacité à
vraiment mettre en oeuvre les
engagements pris en matière commerciale
nous allons nous assurer du maintien de
conditions de concurrence équitables la
proximité commerciale dépendra de notre
convergence réglementaire gelé 10,02
ping c'est la base si nous voulons avoir
zéro de tarif douanier zéro quotas si le
royaume uni ne veut pas suivre cette
ligne de serre au dumping et bien il ne
peut pas avoir zéro tarifs douaniers et
0 quotas les choses sont assez simples
pas à se compliquer autres mesures la
compréhension collective
en revanche je veux vous indiquer
quelque chose ici quelle que soit la
nature de l'accord
quel que soit le degré d'ouverture du
marché intérieur quel qu'il soit il y
aura des contrôles aux frontières
j'insiste sur ce point parce que
libre-échange même maximale ne veut pas
dire absence de contrôle puisque je les
dis comme nous n'avons plus de cour de
justice de l'union européenne pour
chapeauter l'intégralité nos décisions
et notre relation
il nous faudra des contrôles c'est
extrêmement important je pense pour les
sénateurs qui représente des territoires
où il ya des flux matériel des contrôles
je veux donc dire que et bien les
douaniers les services vétérinaires tous
des infrastructures qui ont été bâties
seront utiles ensuite le degré de
contrôle est ce qu on contrôle un sur
cent contre le 10 sur 100 est ce qu'on
peut contrôler 100% à dépendre à
l'accord commercial qu'on trouvera mais
il y aura des contrôles je pense que
c'est extrêmement important qu'on
intègre bien tous cela parce que sinon
on a une vision aussi déformée de la
réalité
notre posture et donc je les dis de ne
pas laisser la pression du calendrier ou
d'un agenda imposer ce faire nous avons
vu michel barnier lundi avec le premier
ministre
la production française est fermée elle
est assumée elle restera pour les
secteurs sensibles en particulier la
pêche
que ce soit pour préserver nous étions
ensemble à port en bessin mardi il ya
une semaine ou dix jours ou qu'un jour
je ne sais plus brefs dix jours
deux bonnes heures à port en bessin sur
la criée avec les pêcheurs normands
on a trois objectifs sur la pêche on va
d'abord l'accès aux eaux puisque si 50%
du poisson est pêché il ya des jours où
c'est 100 % à côté 100% de l'autre le
poisson lui sait pas où est la ligne
imaginaire l'accès aux eaux la gestion
de la ressource
donc il faut bien s'assurer que nous
puissions nous vous accordons des moyens
à ce que nos pêcheurs est durablement
accès la ressource est à dire la
capacité à gérer les stocks et nous
aimerions avoir la garantie que nous
gardons les clés de répartition qui
existent aujourd'hui pas qu'on renégocie
manière annuelle à tout moment les
règles de pêche non seulement avec les
britanniques mais aussi entre européens
donc là il ya des choses qui sont
extrêmement importantes ce que je vais
vous dire c'est que nous avons sur
quatre sujets qui est la gouvernance on
ait parlé l'accord commercial lui-même
le level playing field et la pêche fixé
un principe très fort avec michel
barnier c'est que ces quatre sujets sont
liés certains connaissent les
populations avec clause guillotine vous
savez ces mécanismes ont dit si un de
ces quatre points ne tient plus le reste
ne tient plus je répète pêche accord
commercial level playing field
conditions de concurrence et gouvernance
nous ne serons d'accord sur rien dans ce
cadre là si nous ne sommes pas d'accord
sur tout et donc ça nous met dans une
position de force et donc je reviens à
votre point de calendrier
cette idée du 1er juillet est une idée
de venir d'engagement vis-à-vis de la
filière de l'ue et les perspectives qui
ne tombe pas voyez le 5 décembre pour
une application au 1er janvier mais je
le redis ici il n'y a pas d'accord de
pêche s'est paraît il y aura des
orientations il y aura des principes et
nous espérons pouvoir donner ses
orientations de ses principes au 1er
juillet au plus tard mais nous ne
signerons ses orientations ses principes
s'ils sont si nous trouvons à l'accord
national ce qui est de l'objectif mais
que si nous sommes d'accord sur l'accord
commercial sur les conditions de
conférences et sur la gouvernance est
donc en liant ces quatre sujets je crois
qu'on s'est beaucoup renforcé la main
sur un sujet majeur
il ya un point qui n'est pas dans la
négociation qui sont les services
financiers et britannique aimerait
beaucoup que ce soit dans la négociation
parce qu'ils savent que c'est un sujet
sur lequel les enjeux sont
à de multiples titres importants les
services financiers ne dépendent pas de
ces négociations
l'équivalence financière accordée un
pays tiers est une décision unilatérale
qui n'a pas de permanence dans le temps
qui peut être retiré à tout instant et
donc qui ne se négocie pas donc c'est à
l'union européenne magna autonome
unilatérale de décider si elle accorde
ou non l'équivalence rappelle que en
suisse pour revenir une partie
d'équivalence a été retiré en mode et et
c'est une décision je m'appelle
unilatérale se négocie pas l'autre point
qui n'est pas négociable ce sont les
enjeux de circulation des données
personnelles
là aussi c'est une provision unilatérale
de l'union européenne en tant que telle
avec une décision autonome là aussi ça
ne se négociera pas sur les enjeux de
sécurité de défense
nous cherchons effectivement
appartements et 3 avec deux piliers une
partie sécurité intérieure il partie
plutôt politique étrangère je vous
facilitera l'accès même du président aux
diverses pages qui sont actuellement
dans le mandat sur lequel nous devrions
donc avoir un accord qui vous montrent
que nous cherchons alors je vous donne
les têtes des titres de chapitres mais
donc il ya un chapitre politique
étrangère sécurité défense consultation
et coopération coordination et de
sanctions internationales aux opérations
et missions déploiement extérieur
capabilités de défense et développement
d'une industrie défense donc c'est
notamment l' agence européenne de
défense et les enjeux de développement
de satellites ou les projets qui sont
conduits dans le cadre de la coopération
structurée permanente les les échanges
en termes de renseignements le programme
spatial et la coopération en termes de
développement tout ça vous voyez fait
l'objet de provisions que je porter à
votre connaissance pour que vous voyez
la nature effectivement de l'accord que
nous cherchons mais là aussi le royaume
uni est un état tiers certaines peaux si
certaines programme sa direction surtout
vers des états tiers d'autres ne sont
pas et ne seront pas l'exception
donc voilà pour conclure sur l'enjeu de
la mixité de l'accord nous sommes très
attentifs à la portée juridique et
symbolique des choix que nous effectuons
dans ce cadre parce que quand nous
faisons une chose un jour il peut se
produire d'autres circonstances
ou bien nous aurions créer des
précédents nous cherchons en particulier
à préserver les prérogatives l'après les
prérogatives des parlements nationaux
et ceci dès l'ouverture de négociations
dès le mois de mars si nous mettons
d'accord la semaine prochaine et quelle
que soit l'issue de l'accord en partant
en emportant effectivement une attention
particulière aux questions de mixité
nous l'avons rappelée à michel barnier
l'importance de continuer à informer à
associer les parlements nationaux
quant à l'objet lui-même de mixité nous
avons très avec la commission pour bien
mettre en valeur ce qui dépendra des
compétences exclusives de l'union ce qui
dépend des de compétence des états
qu'elles pouvaient faire porter aux
négociateurs européens pour la cohérence
de d'accord et ce qui correspond à les
compétences mixte la décision que nous
avons prise c'était de ne pas préjuger
de l'accord puisque oui on a l'accord
peut être très large ou plus réduit et
préjugés aujourd'hui de savoir de savoir
s'il sera mixte ou s'il sera de
compétence exclusive n'est pas forcément
utile à la main du négociateur et n'est
pas forcément non plus réaliste sur la
nature c'est un sujet donc que nous
pourrons continuer à suivre très
précisément et nous avons dû n'est pas
tranchée il n'est pas tranchée parce que
non ce que nous avons tranché c'est
qu'il n'était pas tranchée nous avons
tranché l'idée que nous nous parce que
on aurait pu trancher que c'était de la
compétence exclusive pure est d'ores et
déjà dire que ça se ferait à l'unanimité
du conseil avec une soeur ratification
du parlement européen ce n'est pas ce
que nous disons nous disons que nous
étudierons la mixité ou non de l'accord
fonction skhirat dedans et que donc
laissons la possibilité d'avoir
peut-être une partie ratifié d'une
certaine manière une partie ratifié
d'une autre ou l'ensemble ratifié
manière mixte ça mais ça ne pensait pas
tout à fait la voie comprendra mais le
degré de ce qui passera dans les
parlements nationaux dépendra du contenu
voilà tous les enjeux régalien dépendent
par définition beaucoup plus parlements
nationaux que les enjeux commerciaux
mais encore faut-il voir s'il ya
d'anglais la partie régaliennes donc
c'est pour ça que nous avons tranché de
ne pas trancher maintenant
nous sommes enfin pour conclure prêts à
tous les scénarios je crois que une
partie de la crédibilité européenne a
été de se préparer à tous les scénarios
jusqu'à maintenant et le fait que nous
préparions notamment à calais dans les
différents ports normands bretons à
boulogne des infrastructures pour nous
préparer à l'absence d'un accord a rendu
crédible le fait que nous nous
préparions à tous et donc oui nous
allons continuer à des mesures de
préparation
ainsi nombre de mesures d'ailleurs des
ordonnances que vous savez que qui en
avaient été prises vont devoir être
renouvelée puisque parle plus de lui
même du même contexte politique mais les
infrastructures comme je vous ai dit les
mécanismes d'information la frontière
intelligente les recrutements ce soit
les douaniers les gendarmes
nous prolongeons les contrats nous
gardons ces mécanismes en sommeil ils
vont pas être déployé tous les matins
mais capable d'être réveillé tout le
monde et donc pour conclure je le redis
ici sans animosité avec beaucoup
d'amitié envers le royaume uni on ne
peut pas être un pied dedans un pied
dehors
et donc je peux vous assurer que nous ne
sommes ni en position de demandeur ni en
position de faiblesse dans la
négociation du qui s'ouvre nous sommes
avec des principes des convictions des
points de fermeté moi je vous ai exposé
en détails et je serai donc ravis il
vient de préciser encore ceux qui
restent à clarifier pour vous je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre de ces
précisions
on va utiliser la procédure habituelle
de 3,3 par commission tout ça on est
tenu de lever le camp avant 15h alors
donc vous inquiétez pas monsieur emorine
alors mes olivier cadic merci monsieur
le président madame à miss merci
beaucoup merci pour vos propos et votre
vélo cité pour défendre la position de
l'europe dans cette difficile discussion
hier la ministre de l'intérieur brice
battle a annoncé que la mise en place
d'un système à points pour contrôler
l'immigration après le break site avec
une volonté affirmée de fermer sa
frontière ou locuteurs non anglophones
et non qualifiés que prévoit de faire la
france où l'union européenne dans ce
domaine
est ce qu'il ya un principe de
réciprocité qui va être imaginées par
rapport à cette décision parce que là on
est sûr vraiment sur le futur la façon
de vont fonctionner nos entreprises avec
qui aurait besoin d'envoyer
éventuellement des des personnes
travaillent et au royaume uni
ensuite il ya une deuxième préoccupation
qui concerne le secteur status tel qu'il
est appliqué aujourd'hui et cette
préoccupation concerne les personnes
âgées
on a vu que un tiers seulement des
inscrits au consulat a fait sa demande
de cette statue ce n'est assez
préoccupés parce que bien souvent elles
pensent qu'elles ne sont pas concernés
elles sont là depuis tellement longtemps
être son passé ailleurs s'estime plus
concerné par ça ne le découvrent or au
delà du 1er juillet 2021
normalement elles ne seront plus
couvertes ça ne donne pas fait cette
demande de cette eau le status et on
peut imaginer que d'avoir des personnes
très âgées qui arrivent à l'hôpital et
qui ne sont pas du coup protégé du tout
est ce qu'il y a il est prévu de
discuter de ce point là pour les
personnes âgées
merci merci olivier richard yong
résidents une question thématiques
concernant le brevet unitaire
il est prévu qu'il rentre en vigueur dès
que l'allemagne ne ratifiera mais ça
n'est pas tellement la question le
royaume uni jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant a
fait partie de l'accord pour la
juridiction sur le brevet unitaire qui
sera d'ailleurs installé à paris mais la
difficulté c'est que l'instance d'appel
ça sera la cour de justice de l'union
européenne hors boris johnson a rappelé
encore récemment qu'il ne reconnaissait
pas l'autorité de la cour de justice
européenne
alors que que peut-il se passer est ce
que la france souhaite que le royaume
uni quitte
d'accord sur le brevet unitaire ou au
contraire cherchent un moyen de le
maintenir dans l'accord merci jean
françois rapin
oui mais je prie messieurs les
présidents madame la ministre
trois points ont rapidement un point sûr
sûr sûr l'espace ayant vu bien sûr la
demande de diminution des budgets nous
avons demain en assemblée plénière une
discussion sur ce sujet mais mais je ré
insiste sur le fait que je pense que
cette diminution du budget sur l'espace
très délétère serait délétère pour notre
autonomie et notre indépendance
européenne et que de toute façon la
france au regard de ses avancées
seraient coincées dans ses avancées et
nous aurions un retentissement
indéniable sur le budget national parce
que je ne vois pas les programmes
spatiaux s'arrêter ou être être revue à
la baisse à c'est le premier point
deuxième point sur la pêche
vous avez bien exposer votre vision des
choses
en tant que ministre française et je
l'entends très bien et je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec tous les points que
que vous avez levé
simplement je ne suis pas convaincu
qu'il y ait sur le sujet de la part de
nos collègues européens
la même ambition sur sur le sujet de la
bêche donc je j'en appelle à votre
sagacité et à votre volonté de voir une
unité réelle de tous les de tous les
pays des vingt-sept en tout cas sur sur
ce sujet sachant que à mon avis prévoir
le pire c'est nous préparer aux
meilleurs et je voudrais savoir si
effectivement dans le cadre d'un accord
qui serait compliqué ou qui nous verrait
une interdiction d'accès au zoo vous
prévoyez des indemnisations voir des
compensations sur toute la filière je ne
pense pas seulement à la pêche mais sur
toute la filière parce que vous le savez
connaissant bien les hauts de france
aussi bien qu'alex boulogne peut être
impacté boulogne en particulier dans le
cadre du traitement et dernier point je
voudrais vous faire part 2
mas mans ma vision sur l'état d'esprit
général nous étions rien avec quelques
collègues de la commission des finances
à bruxelles dans le cadre de l'article
13 le sénat français a une belle tribune
et je n'ai pas senti dans le cadre des
divers discussion une réelle unité une
unité sur les sujets que vous avez
évoqué de la part des états membres
en tout cas des parlements des
parlements membres et aussi on le sent
très bien aujourd'hui
cette divergence qu'il y a à la fois
entre le conseil la commission et le
parlement
et je ne sais pas si cette bonne augure
pour entrer dans une discussion forte
avec le royaume merci jean françois
ladislas poniatowski mais merci restants
madame la ministre vous avez évoqué
certains sujets qui ne figure pas dans
le projet de mandat des cotations qui va
confier à michel dernier y en a deux
essentielles qui ne figurent pas et moi
je suis stupéfait et je le dirai en tant
que rapporteur d'un ppr je suis
stupéfait parce que chez le barbier nous
a beaucoup parlé ces deux sujets le
premier ce sont les droits des citoyens
ça ne fera pas partie de son mandat
donné que c'est sur c'est à dire ces
fameux 4 millions et demi de personnes 3
million deux cent mille européens qui
vont tu en angleterre vivent travaillent
et où est le billion 2 d'orgueil qui
sont chez nous des anglais ont pris une
mesure importante qui est la création de
ce fameux statut de résident nous
n'avons rien fait il n'y a aucune règle
est prévue dans les 27 pays pour les
anglais qui sont respectivement dans les
autres ça me surprend beaucoup et moi
j'aurais bien aimé que ça fasse partie
des mandats du mandat de michel verdier
le second sujet qu'il a aussi souvent
évoqué chez nous qu'à chaque fois qu'on
l'a auditionné ici c'est l'irlande alors
comme si c'était un sujet réglé terminé
plus besoin d'en parler quand c'est pas
terminé puisque l'irlande du nord
d'avoir un double statut douaniers un
statut douaniers je dirais anglais il va
dépendre des douanes anglaise pour tous
les produits qui voir et venues du monde
entier en irlande du nord
et puis un statut douaniers européens
un pour tous les produits qui iront en
irlande du nord puis en suivant
transiter et venir chez nous c'est un
truc apprécié lors tous les cas c'est un
truc à mon avis impossible à résoudre en
dix mois
enfin je suis surpris de voir que c'est
le second sujet qui ne sera pas confiée
ça fait pas partie du mandat de michel
barnier et je pense que c'est une erreur
ça n'est pas dedans et je pense que pour
tout que pour terminer madame la
ministre vous avez évoqué vous avez
voulu être faire dans dix ans de nous
préparons à tous moi je considère que
nous ne nous préparons pas assez à un
échec comme vous voulez vous qu en dix
mois on règle tous les sujets que vous
avez évoqué tous les trois vous les deux
présidents vous madame la ministre
moi je pense que c'est impossible il ya
cette date butoir je pensais que c'était
pas le 1er mai 15 15 juillet date butoir
cela cadeau qu'ont offert abri johnson
si on n'arrive pas à voir un accord on
peut prolonger la durée de négociations
un an ou deux ans tu as raison de faire
ça jean ila al avance dit je n'en veux
pas j'aurais tout réglé d'ici la fin du
mois de décembre je pense qu'on n'y
arrivera pas et donc je pense qu'on va
un échec
et là je ne suis pas sûr qu'on fasse le
nécessaire pour faire front à un échec
ça veut dire que toutes les mesures
qu'on envisageait une fois les prendre
en toute urgence
ça va être vraiment la course je ne sais
pas quoi
à partir du 4 juillet merci ladislas
robert del picchia ne changera pas
d'avis qu'il prolongera il sera d'accord
pour prolonger ce n'est pas la première
fois que je change de vie madame la
milice moi j'ai un autre sujet qui
m'inquiète
j'entends dans les milieux financiers et
bancaires que les britanniques ne
respecte pas du tout ce que paulo pour
lequel pour lesquels michel barnier
s'était engagé c'est le problème de
contrôle des financements des transferts
de financement dans les pays et chez les
citoyens
il semblerait que dans les banques
britanniques on fasse déjà des
propositions aux clients éventuels et
nouveau qui arrive y compris des
français
de placer de l'argent dans des lieux qui
ne sont pas dans les normes prévues par
le mais oui je crois que c'est celle à
la limite on est on est on dépasse les
limites et donc quid du mandat qu'est ce
qui va se passer parce que michel
barnier va être dans une situation où il
a lui-même lancé cette réforme avec
difficulté mais il y est arrivé et
maintenant on se rend compte que les
britanniques ne le respecte pas et donc
on peut penser qu'ils vont le respecter
de mois en mois merci robert yannick
vaugrenard
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous avez indiqué que vous
aviez comme objectif de faire preuve
d'une certaine fermeté
parallèlement à cela cette ferme était
indispensable
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faille être
aussi parfois rassurant est que l'europe
ne pas seulement économique et
financière mais qu'elle est aussi
diplomatique
dans ce cadre là ne pensez vous pas
qu'il soit nécessaire qu'il y ait des
expressions régulières par rapport à la
question de la défense et de la
nécessité absolue de continuer à
travailler avec les britanniques sur
cette question là sur les questions
spatiales sur les questions
géopolitiques par exemple pour avoir des
positions communes avec les britanniques
à l'onu et notamment au conseil de
sécurité voire sur le plan de la
recherche en général
parallèlement aux négociations et à la
nécessaire fermeté par ailleurs ne sera
qu il ne sera pas difficile d'avoir un
accord global et d'empêcher de se
lézarder
c'est l'union que nous avons vu des 27
pendant les négociations qui ont précédé
le vote du bric site
il est certain que la france aurait
plutôt intérêt à défendre la pêche et
les allemands l'automobile et on sait
pourquoi et donc ceux ci risquent de se
les gardent de se lézarder
le paradoxe je termine par là c'est que
si les choses se passaient de manière
plutôt positive
globalement je doute que nous arrivions
à un accord au 31 décembre
mais imaginons que les choses se passent
de manière positive entre le britannique
et l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne le risque ne serait-il pas
que d'autres pays de l'union et envie
aussi de quitter l'union européenne
non jean yves le conte puis laurence
harribey oui merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je voudrais d'abord
dire que la manière dont on continuera à
assurer les droits des citoyens
européens aux quatre millions et demi de
personnes qui sont impactés par le break
site est essentiel pour l'avenir de la
construction européenne et la
crédibilité de ce que signifie la
citoyenneté européenne
et de ce point de vue là je suis
absolument en ligne avec notre collègue
ladislas poniatowski sur l'absence de
mandat de négociation sur ce sujet on
doit constater que les chiffres que j'ai
quarante pour cent des personnes qui ont
demandé le statut permanent en grande
bretagne n'ont pas reçu de réponse dans
les délais et donc il ya une réelle
inquiétude de ce côté là et ma question
sur ce point est la suivante est ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas plutôt que de
déléguer aux états membres le fait de
donner des droits spécifiques aux
ressortissants britanniques qui sont sur
leur territoire est ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas clairement d'une part être plus
précis sur la volonté non seulement de
maintenir des droits pour les
ressortissants européens qui sont sur le
sol du royaume uni leur droit de séjour
mais aussi la portabilité de leurs
droits sociaux retraite
asus assurance maladie mais que en récit
proc les droits des ressortissants du
royaume uni sur l'ensemble de l'union
européenne fasse partie des engagements
de l'accord de retrait et ne soit pas
déléguer aux différents états membres et
donc soit complètement partie intégrante
de la négociation et soit protégée par
le droit de l'union pour que finalement
si on demande des choses aux
britanniques en réciproque l'union
européenne garantissent aux
ressortissants aux ressortissants
britanniques sur le sol de l'union
européenne
le fait que c'est le droit de l'union
qui leur fait qui lors qu'il aura sur
leurs droits enfin je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur le fait que depuis
le 1er février il ya un certain nombre
de systèmes de transfert d'argent de
grande bretagne vers utilisé par les
ressortissants européens vers un certain
nombre de pays qui ne fonctionnent plus
dans la mesure où effectivement comme ça
a été dit il semblerait que la
régulation ne soit plus aussi solide
qu'auparavant
laurence harribey merci monsieur
président donc j'avais une première
question sur le droit des citoyens je
passe mais je souscris au 2o deux
collègues qui ont soulevé ce problème là
la deuxième question concerne la
question de la gouvernance vous dit que
c'est une question qui est lié aux
autres et qu' il n'est pas question de
ne pas avoir un outil de gouvernance est
un outil de règlement des conflits
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
précisément et est-ce que ça revient pas
finalement à donner un statut spécifique
au royaume uni au regard des autres et
que ça peut donner des idées comme le
disait yannick vaugrenard tout à l'heure
et puis troisième question vous semble
vous avez un propos qui est ferme et
volontariste et on peut vous remercier
de cette transparence et de cette
volonté
mais quid des autres pays et du risque
de lézardes dans l'unité européenne que
l'on a eu à peu près dans la première
phase de ce retrait parce que les enjeux
ne sont pas les mêmes selon les pays et
qu'à un moment donné les pays risquent
de vouloir s'entendre et à aboutir à un
accord sur les domaines qui les
intéresse plus particulièrement
je vous remercie merci didier marie puis
benoît huré ensuite je penserai le
flambeau à christian madame la mise si
je puis me permettre
compte tenu du temps s'il ya des
questions auxquelles vous ne pourriez
pas répondre on pourrait imaginer que
par écrit ou vous les rliss teura vous
pouvez donner des réponses écrites parce
qu on va aborder une période où on va
falloir être de plus en plus pressée y
aura de plus en plus de questions
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre de questions
la première porte sur l'orientation
voulue par johnson dans le cadre de ces
négociations la commune à l'union
européenne a mis sur la table un projet
de mandat ambitieux généreux et on
constate que les demandes formulées par
monsieur johnson sont assez éloignées
des propositions demandent à qui sont
aujourd'hui en discussion
non seulement il considère que onze mois
suffisent
il considère par ailleurs qu'il n'est
pas tenu juridiquement par un alignement
réglementaire et qu'il souhaite diverger
sur les règles européennes en filigramme
ne pensez vous pas qu'il peut viser un
accord est donc une sortie sèche de
l'union européenne
et j'aurais avoir votre sentiment sur le
positionnement politique de monsieur
johnson dans ce cas de figure
deuxième question c'est sur le pilotage
les britanniques refusent aujourd'hui
de se soumettre aux arbitrages de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
dans les relations futures
envisagez-vous comme dans d'autres
accords commerciaux
la mise en place d'un comité mixte ce
qui serait un organe interne de pilotage
de cet accord est donc un organe y
compris de sanction en cas de non
respect de cet accord oui monsieur le
président madame la ministre madame la
ministre
merci pour votre volonté affichée au
niveau de vos engagements pour l'union
européenne
vous l'avez rappelé à la veille du
conseil de l'europe
grosse pierre d'achoppement qui est le
budget de l'europe effectivement il ne
faut pas qu'on se rate
pour la période qui s'ouvre un budget au
rabais serait dangereux pour l'avenir
l'europe
nous avons eu hier ici un colloque de
haut niveau avec des représentants de
différents régions d'europe dont
monsieur alexis s'y passe franchement
c'était de très bonne tenue et je ne
saurais mais je me permettrai pas mais
je vais quand même le faire vous
conseiller dans lire les comptes rendus
et ont ça permette de mieux comprendre
les attentes
les blocages qui sont effectivement réel
quoi qu'il en soit sans moyens
financiers suffisants et ambitieux
nous n'avancerons pas alors au delà des
contributions on est en train de mégoter
sur les pourcentages de cette
contribution de chacun des états vous
avez insisté sur la nécessité je partage
tout à fait d'avoir des ressources
propres
parce qu'il faudra qu'on ait plus de
politique mais je crois qu'il faut
compter aussi dans les esprits
le fait que chaque fois qu'on décide de
transférer plus de compétences au niveau
de l'union européenne parce que l'effet
masse et la pertinence de les conduire à
ce niveau là il faut qu'il y ait
systématiquement le transfert de ce que
chacun des états membres
consacré à cette compétence assuré à ce
niveau-là désormais je prends toujours
un exemple parce que je l' ai vécu et ça
marche bien
quand les communes se sont regroupées en
intercommunalités
nous avons crantée en tous les cas dans
la communauté de communes où je suis
cette automaticité de transfert de
moyens consacrés aux compétences qu'on
exercer seul et qu'on confié maintenant
à l'entité supérieur donc voilà ça c'est
peut-être un aspect qui puisqu'il n'est
pas tout de suite palpable qui ne serait
pas bloquant et qui permettrait d'être
un acquis pour la suite
[Musique]
deux derniers intervenants et line
renaud garabédian madame la ministre
l'année dernière à la suite d'une
décision de la cour de justice
européenne
les français résidant dans l'union
européenne ont bénéficié de
l'exonération du paiement de la csg et
de la crds sur les revenus fonciers qui
étaient encaissés en france est ce que
vous savez si cette exonération va être
reprise dans les accords avec le royaume
uni
car dans le cas contraire bien
évidemment nos compatriotes français
verrait ça d'un très mauvais oeil merci
mamie ministre merci et l'une enfin
hélène conway mouret
merci merci messieurs les présidents
dames la ministre nous faisons le
constat qu'il est important que nous
soyons unis au niveau de l'union
européenne mais le royaume lui ne l'est
pas le royaume les plus unis puisque
l'ecosse et l'irlande du nord
majoritairement voté pour rester dans
l'union européenne ne pas pour sortir
or aujourd'hui nous avons un premier
ministre anglais qui va négocier pour
l'ensemble de ce royaume et moi je
voudrait plaider et deux de mes
collègues l'ont déjà fait pour que les
droits des citoyens sont vraiment pris
en compte parce que en faisant cela à la
fois nous enverront un message très fort
d'une union européenne qui elle reste
ouverte et s'intéresse aux gens et peut
peut-être ainsi combattre les
nationalismes en tout cas le
nationalisme qui est un des courants de
ce bris site est aussi envoyer un
message très fort nos amis écossais et
irlandais du nord qui eux continuent à
être tournés vers vers cette union il
continue à croire en nous donc voilà je
voudrais plaidé pour cela et je rejoins
tout à fait ce que helbling bien mais a
dû dire puisque ayant passé le 31
janvier auprès de nos amis écossais pour
partager leur tristesse et montrer que
nous sommes toujours à leurs côtés
et bien c'est une des questions que les
français vivent en écosse sont opposés à
savoir que est en effet ils vont se
retrouver dans un pays tiers est donc à
nouveau imposé de ce qui lui est ce que
la barre était retirée par la décision
de la cour européenne de justice merci
merci alors madame la ministre
comme on a cinq heures devant nous je
pense que je vais pouvoir répondre en
détail sur chacun des points que vous
avez évoquées je vais faire de mon mieux
et effectivement si les sujets sur
lesquels je suis passé trop vite vous
avez besoin de détails
m une force de frappe collective pour
vous répondre rapidement et précisément
je pense qu'il pourrait être positive
c'est à tort qu'a dit oui sur
l'immigration présentation hier de ce
système à points avec la série de
critères l'anglais une une offre
d'emploi un niveau de salaire minimum
bon bref tant de choses qui montre bien
qu effectivement l'objectif recherché
annoncé pour le moment c'est bien de
donner place à une immigration légale de
travailleurs qualifiés et non et non
plus on n'a en tête que 70% les
européens aujourd'hui sur le sol
britannique
avec le système qui est tel qu'il est
présenté qui n'est pas acceptée par sam
est allé présenter n'aurait pas pu
rentrer donc c'est un changement
effectivement majeur nous avons des
échanges avec mission mise intérieur
avec l'ensemble des relais de
l'administration qui depuis hier essaie
de comprendre ce que ça veut dire
je vais le redire ici il ya une partie
qui tient à la souveraineté nationale ya
une partie qui est aussi liée au marché
intérieur
les quatre libertés du marché intérieur
elles sont liées et donc on ne peut pas
ouvrir totalement une liberté si on n'a
pas la réciprocité
donc c'est là où je mettrais plutôt ça
dans un paquet global
on n'est pas du tout en train
aujourd'hui de vous dire comment on va
faire évoluer notre système mais ce
genre de chose s'apprécie dans la
globalité de la relation tout vous
construire et donc nous suivront
particulièrement avec vigilance aussi ce
que ça peut vouloir dire pour la
frontière britannique gérer sur le sol
français pour calais pour d'autres lieux
tout ça c'est des points sur lequel nous
allons être extrêmement vigilant
attentif et des échanges auront lieu de
manière à la fois bilatérales et puis
collective sur ce sujet par son nombre
de pays européens sont extrêmement nous
nous allons peut-être la pêche comme
point d'attention majeur d'autres pays
ont ce système nouveau d'immigration
particulièrement de manière attentive
dans leurs discussions nationales sur le
site d'actus et les personnes âgées
c'est effectivement un sujet que nous
suivons de très près pour notamment la
communauté française mais plus largement
les européens qui sont au royaume uni je
crois que le consulat appartement
mobilisés mais il est vrai qu'il faut
que nous arrivions
à bien faire comprendre à tous les
européens sur le sol britannique que
c'est un droit que nous leur avons re
pour lequel nous avons bataillé qu'ils
puissent rester au royaume uni dans les
mêmes conditions
s'ils se sont installés avant la fin la
paire de transition donc ces taxis se
sont installées avant le 31 décembre
2020 ou plus longtemps si c'est plonger
mais je crois qu'on a aussi la du
travail à faire et ce sera aussi le cas
je crois de cet organisme de gouvernance
sur le sujet des droits des citoyens la
commission européenne je crois il sera
représenté nous sommes encore à
comprendre comment les choses vont
s'organiser
une somme extrêmement vigilants pour que
nous assurions sur ce point là un
travail collectif européen qui soit à la
hauteur des attentes des citoyens qui
sont sur le sol britannique installé et
qu'y at-il donc on doit assurer
réellement la protection de leurs droits
monsieur ses interviews sur le brevet
unitaire bon c'est un sujet qui est au
coeur du marché unique
effectivement il n'est pas encore en
vigueur mais je peux vous dire qu'il est
hors mandat et qui n'est pas qu'ils
estiment que le pays tiers donc je
pourrais préciser si besoin
je pense qu'avec ce que je ne vous dirai
ça clarifie beaucoup de vos questions
sur ce point il n'est pas il n'est pas
prévu que ce régime de brevet unitaire
soi ou vers des pays tiers
et donc il est hors mandat de
négociation monsieur le sénateur rapin
sur l'espace et le cfp effectivement
c'est une de nos priorités
thierry breton l'a dit l'a martelé elle
a rappelé c'est à mes yeux des éléments
souveraineté est essentielle
le fonds européen de défense l'espace la
politique de recherche fonde sont au
coeur notre capacité à préparer futur en
tant qu'européen
au delà de préparer le futur tout court
mais il faut aussi qu'on prépare le
futur que nous européens désirons donc
c'est un sujet que nous suivons de très
près sur la pêche je tiens faire une
précision
boris johnson dans son discours à
greenwich au le 3 février au matin n'a
jamais dit qu'il voulait la fermeture
des eaux britanniques et cet acharnement
pied important à noter pendant des mois
et des mois on nous expliquait que les
eaux britanniques seront pour les
pêcheurs britannique
j'entends du bourg et j'ose le dire les
eaux britanniques sont sous contrôle
britannique et nous chercherons à voir
un accord avec l'union européenne
tous les ans point de départ la
négociation je vous ai dit je pense
qu'il ya des choses à mettre dans cet
accord banques sont un bon accord un
accord qui permette à toute la filière
de travailler effectivement y'a pas que
les gens sont à quai il ya tout ce que
les emplois les dizaines de milliers
d'emplois de la filière dans son
ensemble
je pense qu'il est important de si vous
l'avez pas fait lisez ce discours qui a
son charme de poésie est en tout cas
d'affirmations parfois un peu de lait
mosson son intéressant à connaître mais
sur la pêche spécifiquement je vous
invite vraiment à regarder parce que il
faut avoir en tête qu'il n'est plus
question à ce stade de la part des
britanniques de parler d'une fermeture
pure et simple des eaux britanniques
ensuite il faut qu'on négocie un bon
accord je pense que c'est la clé du
travail vous vous évoquez à ce qu'on
entre vous les divisions entre les 27
s'il ya bien un acteur avec lequel je
peux vous dire que la france
le conseil la commission n'est pas n'est
pas loin c'est le parlement européen je
vous invite à aussi si vous suivez le
débat en détails à lire la résolution du
parlement européen sur le mandat du bric
site elle est très claire et les mots
que je devant vous sont des mots qui se
retrouve largement cette résolution
donc si vous avez le parlement européen
si vous avez des états membres qui sont
les ceux qui sont particulièrement
impactés parce que géographiquement plus
proche et qui travaille bien avec la
commission on voit bien que l'unité
aussi des pays derrière et de votre
expérience
d'autres parlements nationaux des pays
pour qui la réalité politique interne de
sujets quand même bien plus faible que
chez nous mais dans les échanges
politiques au niveau ministériel avec le
parlement avec la commission je pense
que le signal de la résolution du
parlement européen est un signal
politique majeure et je vous invite à
lire parce que je pense que vous la
trouverez en tout cas pas rassurante
notre cas intéressant de nombreux titres
monsieur peut n'être aussi alors je
pense qu'il ya un petit malentendu ou en
tout cas dans ce que vous dites
beaucoup des points que vous évoquez
sont réglés il faisait partie du monde
de l'accord de retrait c'est d'accord il
est rentré dans le droit international
il est rentré en vigueur partout moment
été signés ils étaient d'application
immédiate
en tout cas de l'application au 31
janvier donc sur les droits des citoyens
les choses sont en place je sais que je
comprends pas bien ce que vous dites en
france ce sera un système permettra en
ligne à chaque ou dans les préfectures
mais un système très simple permettre à
tous les citoyens britanniques d
le 1er juillet que seul questionnaire
pourra préciser les choses d'avoir accès
à des titres de séjour dix ans ou plus
ou des ch'ti de séjour renouvelable tout
tout ça était préparé c'était préparé
avec les britanniques s'étaient préparés
de notre côté c'était préparé en
collaboration avec la commission
européenne
donc les choses ne sont pas aujourd'hui
activé et des britanniques qui
voudraient aujourd'hui un titre
d'ailleurs on n'a pas besoin puisqu'ils
sont protégés jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020
et donc nous sommes en train de mettre
en place les procédures mais je pense
qu'il faut pas donner l'impression que
nous n'aurions rien fait au contraire
mais nous avons du temps les choses se
sont stabilisées et vous imaginez bien
qu'il n'y a aucune volonté notre côté de
rendre la vie des britanniques en france
plus compliqué des choses sont claires
sur l'irlande ayant de la même chose
c'est réglé au sens où nous avons le
cadre et où je peux vous dire que et
michel barnier et phil hogan j'étais ya
dix jours à la commission européenne
tout le monde et nous états membres y
compris sommes extrêmement vigilants sur
la mise en oeuvre de l'accord il doit y
avoir des contrôles en mer d'irlande
parce que tous les produits qui
arriveront qui passeront de la grande
île britannique à l'irlande du nord et
qui passerait cette mer d'irlande
doivent être contrôlés au même titre que
s'il est entrée dans le marché intérieur
et nous avons délégué les contrôles
européens aux douaniers britanniques qui
doivent le faire selon les engagements
qu'ils ont pris pour nous assurer que
tout bien qu'ils arriveraient en irlande
du nord et qui ne seraient plus
contrôlée de qu'on pourrait arriver très
facilement en irlande est donc
automatiquement chez nous et partout en
europe soit contrôlée selon des
procédures donc là il ya un point jeu
comme sur le droit des citoyens
les engagements pris doivent être tenues
et je peux vous dire avec derrière le
fait que s'il ne contrôle pas comme nous
le souhaiterions nous avons là aussi des
mesures claires de mise en oeuvre sur le
terrain ou de rétorsion et je veux dire
on a fini une négociation des
engagements les engagements pris doivent
être tenues sinon comme à quoi ça sert
de faire une nouvelle négociation sur le
joli sur le comité de suivi des droits
des citoyens et sur cette question
d'irlande la priorité n'est plus à
négocier
il est plus question d'être caution
avant le mandat c
le contrôle et à la mise en oeuvre et
c'est là où je fais le point avec le
sujet de la gouvernance c'est bien pour
cela que dans le cas de la gouvernance
future nous devons nous armer pour
pouvoir si les engagements futurs sont
pris et ne sont pas tenues avoir
rétorsion sanctions sauvegarde
suspension au potentiel et donc c'est
dans ce même état d'esprit qu'on
travaille sur les certains d'entre vous
ont parlé voilà qu'est ce qui se passe
si on n'a pas d'accord là aussi l'accord
de retrait a déjà réglé à ce nombre de
points il a réglé sujet des citoyens il
a réglé le sujet de l'irlande
il arrivait sujets d'accords financiers
et donc s'il n'y avait pas d'accord au
31 décembre nous tomberions dans le
régime omc
je tiens à vous dire que quand boris
johnson dit moi je souhaite un accord à
l'australienne il n'y a pas d'accord
commercial entre l'union et l'australie
aujourd'hui
donc ça veut dire qu'il nous dit je suis
prêt à aller un régime omc
mais un régime au mc ce n'est pas un
régime où il y aurait zéro tarifs
douaniers
c'est pas un régime ou y aurait zéro
quotas et donc nos entreprises je vous
le dis il faut qu'on leur fasse bien
appréhendé il y aura des contrôles aux
frontières ce qui s'ajoutera c'est qu'il
y aura préemption de droits de douane
mais je pense qu'il faut avoir en tête
on n'est plus du tout dans la même
situation de chute brutale parce que
l'accord de retraite me donne quand même
déjà beaucoup de par beaucoup nous
assure ce nombre de protections et donc
m'interroge dit également
d'autres d'entre vous est ce que ben
johnson voulait au fond voilà de
monsieur 7h mari est ce que il ya un
accord at-il désirer je sais pas s'il
désirait mais voient ce qui se passerait
je tiens juste à doter devant vous que
les milieux d'affaires britanniques
veulent continuer à avoir accès au
marché intérieur de la manière la plus
ouverte possible dans un casse 65
millions de consommateurs avaient cassé
460 millions à une entreprise qui est
basé au royaume uni elle a plutôt
intérêt à avoir accès toujours à 14,5
millions de consommateurs plutôt qu'à 65
millions seulement et donc il ya un
ensemble d'acteurs au royaume uni au
delà potentiellement de certaines les
causses ou ailleurs mais il ya cependant
d'entreprise qui d'ailleurs vient nous
voir mais qui je l'espère vont voir leur
gouvernement d'abord en priorité
qui nous dit ce qu'elle veut conserver
les mêmes règles parce que c'est pour
elle la garantie d'avoir accès à un
grand marché et donc tout ça à mes yeux
n'est pas n'est pas réglée sur la
gouvernance je pense que je vous ai dit
vous dit ce sera un statut madame est
arrivé oui c'est un statut différent et
mais c'est un pays tiers nous avons des
organismes les organes de gouvernance
avec d'autres pays tiers nous allons à
moins d'un cas du ceta qui en suit plus
ou moins alors et certains y voient des
limites ça mais c'est un cadeau ya pas
de statuts différents
c'est juste c'est un accord de libre
échange sans rôle pour la cour de
justice de l'union européenne dans le
cadre de l'accord de libre échange et
donc d'autres pays ont avec nous des
organismes de gouvernance est différente
entre xittel brésilien andré on n'est
pas un pied dedans un pied dehors
monsieur le sénateur le compte sur les
citoyens je pense que je comprends bien
votre remarque
je crois qu'on pourra y revenir sur les
détails des éléments de vigilance mais
c'est au coeur pour nous de la capacité
à créer de la confiance
les engagements pris doivent être tenues
et sur les droits des citoyens en
particulier sur les sujets fiscaux
monsieur center d'elle pillage dépit del
picchia
financiers fiscaux je joue hier il s'est
passé quelque chose d'important au
conseil ecofin
les îles caïmans ont été rajoutés à la
liste noire des paradis fiscaux l'union
européenne
bon donc ça veut quand même dire que
l'union européenne à des outils et
qu'elle peut ne pas laisser faire
n'importe quoi évidemment ce qu'on
appelle là le dumping fiscal
que ce soit pour les entreprises ou les
particuliers est pour nous un sujet de
vigilance et michel barnier a l'avantagé
de bien connaître le sujet des services
financiers et c'est un sujet sur lequel
j'ai pu échanger déjà avec lui quand
j'avais vu il ya dix jours je pense que
la notion de progrès monsieur le
sénateur vaugrenard dans le cadre des
instances multilatérales
évidemment qu'il faut qu'on puisse se
coordonner et donc il ya un format xml
faudra que trois qui le format aux
nations unies classique allemagne france
royaume uni que nous allons je pense
activé en tout cas utiliser de manière
sûrement plus fréquentes qu'avant
puisque avant nous avions la possible et
nous coordonner dans les instances de
l'union évidemment que sur un nombre de
sujets je crois pas que les britanniques
vont se désolidariser systématiquement
et il ya du coup pour la diplomatie
aussi à reprendre un contact de travail
bilatéral ou collectifs sur des sujets
où nous étions effectivement dans le
cadre européen jusqu'à maintenant sur le
risque politique chiens ici est très
clair nous ne sommes pas dans une
logique de punition ou de revanche
je le dis parce que politiquement c'est
très important de le dire maintenant
nous sommes dues posions qui est
économiquement rationnel à tel point
d'ailleurs que la position des finances
sur le respect des mêmes règles et la
position d'un stand d'entreprises
britanniques et c'est pas un mystère que
de le dire mais effectivement ce que je
vous ai dit initialement dix ans peut
pas être un pied dehors et un pied
dedans montre bien que le brésil doit
avoir des conséquences
le statu quo ne peut pas pris mais parce
que si vous avez exactement les mêmes
avantages
quand vous êtes dehors quand vous êtes
dedans pourquoi donc accepter les
contraintes du monde dedans mais c'est
là où j'aimerais vous dire une chose
les agriculteurs britannique il ya plus
de pâques les élus locaux briques les
élus locaux britannique il n'y a plus de
politique de cohésion de soutien
les chercheurs britanniques si leur
gouvernement ne demande pas à participer
exclusivement aux programmes de
recherche
ils seront tenus hors des programmes
horizon europe et de coordination
erasmus s'il n'est pas demandé
explicitement avec une contribution et
c'est donc il faut quand même en tête
que il ya une partie politique mais
aussi une partie concrètes et l'europe
c'est pas de la politique étrangère
l'europe ça crée des politiques
quotidiennes et donc mon sujet c'est pas
je n'ai pas de craintes sur le fait que
le brésil amènerait un statu quo ou
n'amènera aucune différence dans la vie
des britanniques je pense qu'il va y
avoir quelle que soit l'intérêt l'accord
beaucoup de différence
après notre but n'est pas de les
pénaliser n'est pas de les punir mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on reste notre côté
européen très ferme sur le fait que nos
positions a beau être rationnel mais que
si nous signons nous signons un accord
qui ne nous laisse pas de regrets quand
on a de capacité à protéger sans les
favoris mais à les protéger à regarder
cet équilibre et cette loyauté cette
réciprocité pour nos acteurs économiques
pour conclure sur très très rapidement
sénateurs eurent et sénatrices
d'ailleurs j'ai pris cette heure il y
avait des sénatrices ensuite sénateurs
eurent et oui pour le csp évidemment je
vais lire avec intérêt les débats de
vous avez juillet mais si l'europe
le parallèle que vous faites avec des
intercommunautés est très intéressant
président dit souvent des compétences
avec des responsabilités et c'est réglé
moyens il a si souvent sur le côté
responsabilité c'est pas tout dans la
compétence il faut être capable ensuite
de dire que s'il sait pas bien fait ça
c'est pas bien fait parce qu'ils ont
voulu la compétence mais au niveau
européen je pense que effectivement trop
souvent on veut faire des choses
ensemble s'en donne les moyens de faire
je vous le dis très clairement la
position des états frugaux c'est une
europe aura baissé de voile à combien on
est prêt à mettre sur la table et à
partir de là comment on se répartit de
gâteaux mais les choses marchent à
l'envers c'est peu quels sont les
engagements qu'on a pris parce qu'on
pense qu'on ne peut pas faire chacun
tout seul assez pour être vraiment
souverain vraiment convergent vraiment
réactif et dans ce cas-là mettons-y les
moyens là où jean arthuis notamment
avaient un point important c'est qu'il
dit il faut qu'à la fin la somme des
dépenses publiques soit pas double c'est
parce qu'on paye deux fois ci on paye si
on continue de faire tout
mais mon niveau national puis en plus on
fait tout encore plus haut niveau
européen on a un problème et donc c'est
pour ça que la bataille sur les
ressources propres sur le fait que le
mécanisme d'inclusion carbone aux
frontières peut financer sur la taxe
plastique sur les gaffes à sur la taxe
les transactions financières on a un
stand d'outils qu'il faut qu'on met dans
le débat
à ce stade on a deux qui sont plutôt
plus mûr c'est la taxe ats au dessus
d'un certain niveau de prix du co2 est
bien ce que ça rapporte va au budget
européen pour financer la transition
écologique en particulier
et puis il ce qu'on appelle la taxe
plastique c'est déjà bas quand on est
inondé de plastique par des gens qui
nous a pensé à l'extérieur et qui ne se
soucie absolument pas du coût de
recyclage et ben les pays on recycle
plus on paye un peu moins les payons
aussi que - c'est sa part est une
contribution intéressante on est dans ce
travail là parce qu'effectivement sinon
on est très décalé on est incohérent
entre ce qu'on dit et ce qu'on arrive à
faire
madame à cette triste garabédian sur csg
crds c'est un sujet bilatérales c'est un
sujet qui consomment pas l'union
européenne c'est un sujet sur lequel je
vais m'empresser de vous diriger vers à
la fois gérald darmanin
et puis voilà les instances financières
et budgétaires
mais ce n'est pas un sujet qui est donc
dans le mandat européen bien français et
et qui concède d'ailleurs les citoyens
français avant même est un sujet
bilatérales et puis enfin madame la
sénatrice
oui je crois que l'unité du royaume uni
je peux pas moins évidente à voir ici
une parole politique
maintenant j'ai une parole sur l'état de
droit je pense qu'il est extrêmement
important que nous ayons une vigilance
mutuelle collective sur le fait que la
constitution dans chacun des pays qui
sont nos partenaires soient plaints de
me respecter ça concerne c'est l'unité
constituaient les politiques d'espagne
du royaume-uni de tous les pays qui nous
entourent nous sommes extrêmement
attachés à ce qu'on appelle l'état de
droit et donc fait que les choses se
fassent en suivant et en pleinement
respectant pleinement la constitution
voilà vous venez d'assister à l'audition
d'amélie de montchalin nous ne signerons
pas le 31 décembre à 23 heures un
mauvais accord sous prétexte qu'il faut
signer voilà entre autres ce qui a
déclaré la secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes place maintenant à
la négociation autour des futures
relations entre londres et bruxelles
on sera
évidemment amené en reparler sur public
sénat en attendant je vous souhaite une
excellente journée sur notre antenne
[Musique]